the misery index this is a new show that
you're talking about and it's what you
describe it because it's a fascinating
idea it's a disgusting game show that I
am the host of and I'm very proud of it
and I host it with the Impractical
Jokers the tenderloins I am v tenderloin
the tandoori tenderloin and it's a game
show where you have a scale of 1 to 100
you have all these different real life
miserable events and they're just based
on funny human error and you have to
figure out where they land on the scale
of 1 to 100 in order to win $30,000 and
it's really funny and it's really gross
and it's one of the most fun jobs I've
ever had is there anything that you've
had to cut it didn't make air because it
was too much you just thought well we
can't have that no a TBS have no
boundaries I'd like to visit there was a
point where terrible taste
it was amazing there was this moment
genuinely on set during season 1 we just
got picked up season 2 which is super
exciting you had four five comedians
going to the network saying there are
too many jokes about which has never
happened in the history of the world
that way around has never happened we
were trying to complain to her we wanted
to have less poo and jokes and we were
denied I know as the founding fathers
intended in this country this country is
moving inexorably forward and upward to
a greater place I just didn't know how
dangerous it was until I made this show
it's really dangerous are you guys okay
dangerous in what sense
just so many mishaps what are you
talking about in this house there's
Weir's hats with what Dennis I mean
balls in general are such a liability I
didn't know what you guys go through
there was this one guy who was sitting
on one of those chairs from Ikea that
has all the different shaped holes on it
and he was sitting on it and says his
balls are dangling down through one of
the hosts there's a man here dying in
the audience
and when because of the heat of the
shower his balls started to swell and
then they got stuck under because
they've now become too big to get out
through the same hole and he had to go
to the hospital
well dangerous who said there's no
must-see TV anymore
that's the misery index there's so many
questions the misery index airs Tuesdays
at 10:30 right here on TBS you sold this
out of that
[Laughter]
[Applause]